今日も、静岡の街は
とっても平和。
でも、
ある男が
とんでもないことを考えていました。
ピピッ（カード）
あぁやべっ
よいしょー
いやーいい天気だなー
という訳でわたくしはじめじゃちょー今
とある駐車場の屋上にいます。
車は全然停まってないので、
かなりスカスカな状態なんですけども、
今回もまたしょうもない企画を考えてしまいました。
ぇと僕、今車でこの駐車場の屋上に来たんですけも、
車今停めてるんですけども、今からこの車、
2日間か3日間程、ここで、放置します。放置すると何が起きるっていうと、
駐車料金、
駐車料金が発生すると。
うぅ～、楽しみだなぁ。駐車料金なんですども、
直接駐車場の人に聞きました。駐車場の人に聞いたところ、この駐車場どうやら、
上限金額が無いらしくて。まぁ、言うてしまうと「何日間でも停めていいよ。」
というわけでございます。へっへっへっへっ。
料金表見てください。1時間目!学校の授業みたい。１時間目300円
で、２時間経つとプラス３００円
３時間経つとプラス２００円
４時間経つと２００円
まあ４時間停めると１０００円位取られると
で５時間経つと１２００円
６時間経つと１４００円
以後１時間ごと１００円ということで
ただいま今、本日9月27日の15時でございます。
明日のたぶん夜かな?明日の夜に
東海オンエアが僕ん家に遊びに来ます
てつや達ね
たぶんてつや達は車で来るんですけども
今回はちょっとドッキリしようと思いまして
てつや達の車を使ってたぶんね29(9月29日)かな？
みんなでラーメンを食いに行こうみたいなことを適当に言って、
この駐車場にてつやの車を駐車させて、
まぁラーメン喰いに行くだけなんで、もう、すぐ駐車して、すぐラーメン喰って帰ってきて、一時間ぐらいなんで、
料金的には大体300円くらいだとてつやは思い込んでいるところを
こっそりてつやの駐車券と僕のこの
すごい金額がたまっている駐車券を入れ替えて、
もし、一時間しか停めていない駐車料金がものすごい金額になっていたら
てつやはどういうリアクションをするのか
駐車料金ドッキリを今回してみようと思います。
三日間にわたるドッキリですからね。
いやぁ、楽しみだな。
果たしててつやはどういうリアクションをするのでしょうか。
見てみましょう
じゃっ！二日後に会いましょう。バイバイ
てつやと今日はドライブでしたね。
ただのドライブでした
で、とりあえず今はね、もうお昼なんで、
お昼ご飯を食べててつやが帰るという
お話でございます。
で、俺が帰るまでの映像を…撮ってそれを送ってあげればいいですか?
そう！
で、それ、耐久？
耐久。
やっぱリス顔の人が結構好きなんだよ。
わかる。とてもわかる。
前歯はちょっと出てほしい。
わかる。
大体の人、なんか、そこにコンプレックスを抱またかわいいよね
あー、確かに。
こう、隠すんだよね。こう…こう
でた7号。
稲森パーキング7号来ました！
これ、なんか、あれですか?
きたー
我々の時代です。
OK
あっ、あ…あやべぇ…
あぁぁぁぁ！！！！！！
え！？
え？まってヤバい…。
やべぇやべぇやべぇ
え？やばいことしたこれ…。
やばいこれ、あかんことした。
直してくれなかったら、俺ら一生出れないですよ、ここから。
え？ガチじゃん！
出れないじゃん！！
とりあえず、謝りに行こう…。
はい、なにか？
あの…。勢い余ってしまいました…。
ありがとうございます。
皆さん、稲盛7号、ぜひ。ご利用ください。
URLのリンクが…
住所載ってますので
稲森パーキング7号で御座います
こちらでございますね。
いいですね。
ラーメンが来るんだから！
店員さん「はい、いらっしゃいませ！」
あー！
いやぁ、てつやさんおいしかったですね。
いやいやいやいや、
ぃや、ありがとうてつや本当に
楽しかったですよ。
久しぶりだったね
なんと！一時間300円という激安料金です。
すご！
あぁ、お母さんただいま！
はい。
帰ってきましたよ。僕。
帰ってきましたか。
よかったぁ、よく頑張ったよ。
券も無事ですよ
無事に出るまで(笑)
まだここからっすからね
そうまだここから先がね。
このパーキングのこ…
えぇ！？
ん？何を?どうやって？
あの、事前に僕も駐車してて、
4日前から
え！？
あぁ、あれか。
上の
あっ、そうです。
そう、3日前から屋上に一台停まってるんですよ
というわけで、
一時間停めただけなのに、すごい大量のお金請求されるドッキリ～
テッテレ～
(笑)
８０００円…
いやぁ、この時のために俺は4日前から仕込んでたわけだよてつや～。
いやなんか、
サブチャン撮るなぁ～と思ったぁ。
てつやと静岡をまわるサブチャンシリーズは？
あんなのないよ～
えぇ～！？